we bought all the chicken sandwiches
from every fast food chain in the US and
the UK to compare the differences this
is food Wars
at a UK McDonald's chicken sandwiches
come in three sizes the Mayo chicken a
milk chicken sandwich and a MC crispy
McDonald's in the US has four chicken
sandwich options the McChicken the
mcrispie the mcrispie deluxe and the
McRibs cripsy and the mcrispy spicy
deluxe
the UK KFC options are a regular chicken
sandwich a tower Burger which is the
same but with a hash brown and some
cheese and a stacker Burger which is two
chicken patties with some cheese as well
you see options we currently have two
the Chicken Little look at this little
guy
so little and the KFC chicken sandwich
it's part of a gourmet Kings range
[Music]
whoops
we have two types of chicken sandwich at
a UK Burger King the chicken Royale or
the steakhouse crispy chicken Burger
King in the US also has two chicken
sandwich options and they are as follows
I am taking this off
uh the chicken Junior
this guy I mean this looks exactly like
a McChicken and the original chicken
sandwich the only chicken sandwich we're
gonna see today that is shaped like a
smartphone
Popeye's chicken sandwiches in the UK
only come in one size the classic
chicken sandwich Popeyes in the US also
has but one chicken sandwich Shake Shack
in the UK only has one size of chicken
burger the Chicken Shack Shake Shack we
haven't done anything with Shake Shack
in years of
but they're back they got a chicken
sandwich just on looks whoa this looks
ridiculously Good jelly beans chicken
burgers come in two sizes in the UK as a
standard or as a double
Jollibee I love Jollibee and their
chicken sandwiches are very good we have
their regular chicken sandwich and the
spicy
Wendy's in the U.S went all in on
chicken sandwiches as you can see there
are nine varieties two four yeah Wendy's
only has one size of chicken sandwich in
the UK
okay
um I'm sorry what sandwich is this again
and the crispy chicken sandwich chicken
BLT okay okay okay
Asiago Club spicy chicken sandwich
Wendy's all right we got it BLT or Club
spicy ghost pepper bacon pretzel Pub
Wendy's spicy pretzel
then we've got some options that you
won't find in the U.S two things from a
chain called Molly's a strip burger and
a fillet burger and one thing from
Nando's the grilled chicken burger
Arby's which is only available in the
U.S has three chicken sandwiches
starting over here they have their
crispy chicken sandwich they have their
bacon Swiss crispy chicken sandwich and
they got the buffalo chicken sandwich
Chick-fil-A of course the original you
can also get the same sandwich spicy
version Raising Cane's they have of
course one chicken sandwich option on
the menu this is that uh depending where
you are in the United States these are
the five Carl's Jr slash Hardee's
chicken sandwiches
[Music]
so here are almost all of the chicken
burgers you'll find in the UK arrange by
Price the cheapest at this end is the
McDonald's marrow chicken at just one
pound 19 the most expensive is the Shake
Shack Chicken Shack coming in at nine
pounds and 35 Pence for the price of one
Shake Shack Chicken Shack you could buy
7.8 McDonald's Mayo chickens in general
I think it seems like the size is
tracking with the price so they do seem
a little bit smaller down this end and a
little bit bigger down this end with a
couple of exceptions I do think the
Nando's one looks a little bit small
even the Chicken Shack does look a bit
small and that's very expensive okay
prices in the US uh starting from least
expensive to most expensive the least
expensive sandwich to No Surprise is the
KFC chicken little which comes in a 2.39
but let's be honest this isn't actually
a full sandwich I mean it's almost like
a little slider the most expensive is
the Carl's Jr bacon Swiss chicken
sandwich coming in just the sandwich
11.49 you know I think it's interesting
that McDonald's takes up this part
Wendy's is almost all exactly right here
Arby's is almost exactly right over here
I do enjoy Raising Cane's but this
sandwich should not be in this
percentage of price
um first of all it's chicken tender
sandwiches it's not even like a full
chicken patty I mean the Jollibee spicy
and regular are you know in the lower
third this is a great sandwich Popeyes
is here KFC is right here Popeyes and
KFC positioned almost right next to each
other price
a lot of people myself included would
say this might be these might be the
best fast food crispy chicken sandwiches
on the market
they're down here man they're like
hovering around McChicken prices
apparently UK chicken sandwich is
ordered by weight the lightest option is
the Mayo chicken at 120 grams and the
heaviest is the KFC Zinger stacker
Burger 325 grams key takeaways there a
few of them really dropped down for
example The Shake Shack Burger the
Nando's Burger has really plummeted in
terms of price versus weight not a lot
of movement at the bottom end of the
table which is interesting I think even
just visually like the colors are quite
interesting down the Mayo chicken end
the buns are kind of very dull quite a
matte finish then the sesame seeds kind
of start to disappear the higher up you
go and you head more towards the kind of
brioche bun which just looks a little
bit fancier and shinier okay now this is
all the U.S sandwiches by weight least
weight down here most weight down there
okay once again the Chicken Little and
the Wendy's crispy chicken is at the
very end of the smallest and all the way
down here at the end the Wendy's classic
pretzel bacon pub at a hefty 284 grams
on this one have you sandwich I don't
know what you want to do with this
information really the one thing I will
notice is the most expensive one or the
one of the most expensive ones is the
weight right in the middle
so still not charging by volume shame on
you Carl's Jr Popeyes right Popeyes is
over here move this way all the way up
so lesser in price more in weight let's
go and here are all the chicken
sandwiches arranged in order of price by
weight so the best value in terms of
price by weight is the McDonald's Mayo
chicken per 100 grams of burger that
will cost you just 99p the most
expensive by weight is the Shake Shack
Chicken Shack per 100 grams of burger
that one will cost you 4 pounds 25. The
Shake Shack Burger is 329 more expensive
than the Mayo chicken I guess ultimately
it comes down to personal preference as
to whether you want to pay a little bit
more for what you would hope to be
higher quality or if you kind of just
want value for money and quantity over
quality I think when it comes to fast
food I kind of just want value for money
I just want to leave feeling satisfied
with my food for as little price as
possible I'm kind of surprised how low
down in the value scale the chicken
Royale from Burger King and the standard
fillet burger from KFC ended up you're
really not getting that much value for
money when compared to some of these
options and I don't think the quality of
either of those jeans is necessarily
High Enough justify that price point for
example I think the Jollibee double
chicken sandwich as well as the Zinger
stacker Burger you're getting a lot of
food for your money there and honestly
these are really tasty Burgers so the
quality is good price is good I think
these ones are what I would lean towards
in general if I were to order this this
order from Best Value to worst value
coming in
[Music]
as a Wendy's BLT look at this little guy
what a deal I love the fact that both
the Popeyes and the KFC chicken
sandwiches are arguably the best deal
you can get in the U.S look at this if
you're going per 100 grams of Chicken
Little isn't as good of a deal as a full
chicken sandwich I love it
um glad to see the pretzel buns are down
here because these are the heaviest but
also comparing it with the price you get
a pretty good deal I think from here on
it's like yeah okay
um
back here Jollibee spicy chicken glad to
see it great deal mix chickens over here
huh Raising Cane's all right I was a
little tough on Raising Cane's before
everyone's favorite Chick-fil-A
Chick-fil-A here and here really really
this is your favorite restaurant we're
closed on Sundays for this give me a
break Shake Shacks over here
I don't know I was enticed by its size
but after running the numbers it's not
that good of a deal shame on you Shake
Shack I know McDonald's even McDonald's
isn't safe
Therma crispy all the way over here for
this one
that's surprising and annoying look at
this look at this every Carl's Jr most
expensive right they weren't the
heaviest worst value the Carl's Jr hand
breaded not even the ones with all the
fun stuff on it just a regular ham
breaded sandwich here you go it was
10.99 and it weighed 221 grams so it's
4.97 per 100 grams I know it's a lot of
data to throw at you let me just give
you the tldr too expensive
so here are all the UK's standard
chicken sandwiches I'm going to taste
them all back to back and provide you
with my definitive ranking here are the
standard chicken sandwiches at several
U.S fast food chains I'm gonna try and
rank them right now McDonald's MC crispy
I just want to try they've gone really
heavy on the mayor
the bun is quite fancy it's fancier than
you'd normally find on a McDonald's
burger it's kind of like a pretzel bun
effect nice shiny decent texture on it
not too doughy chicken patty maybe a
little bit thin it's a good place to
start because I think there is room for
improvement there but it could be a lot
worse so starting with down here in the
chicken classic I mean I feel like I'm a
bit biased because I've been eating
these as long as I can remember
I'll put it here for now I feel like I
mean it's good for its value but
I don't know a little basic
now I don't think I've had this one
before the Burger King one
hmm
similar actually I like the better yeah
BK all right
next up we've got the KFC fillet Burger
by the looks of things also just mayo
and lettuce and chicken
overall it's just lacking a little bit
of something it's quite Bland I think so
far whether it's the chicken
the breading or the Mayo not quite as
flavorful as they look crispy so
slightly below it let me combine Popeyes
chicken sandwiches has been sitting for
a while this is the one that everyone
lost their minds about on the internet
so
everything I'm looking for still crispy
amazing Popeyes flavor love the bun a
little bit of mayo or sauce on there not
too overpowering wow that's great
they'll stay in this region
big competitor though KFC ooh this one
this is still really crispy all right
you heard enough crunch yeah
I'm going in for another bite
the Burger King chicken Royale I'm
tempted to dock points just because of
how stupid this thing looks I've never
understood why they made it long
I think the ratio
is slightly off the bun is obviously a
long bun but it's also quite thick
so if you can see that you're getting
like quite a lot of bread to meet ratio
yeah that's the worst one so far
um
Wendy's we saw we'll see later Wendy's
head you know
100 freaking sandwiches
dry barely seasoned no that's that's
that's the worst one let's cheese on
this now
not very good Popeye's Chicken Sandwich
Popeyes is a relatively recent addition
to the UK we didn't have this until
maybe a year or two ago and I will say
so far people seem to be liking it on
this one you get the chicken the Mayo
and instead of the lettuce you get
pickles which I think is more of an
American thing
I'm one that I enjoy because I love
pickles
foreign
this is good I think we have a leader so
far
the chicken I would say is thicker and
crispier than any of the three I've
tried so far A little like crunchy bits
that flake off the edge
so yeah I think my favorite so far
Popeyes Arby's I mean
they got the meats and I guess chickens
are meat but I don't think about getting
chicken when I go to Arby's it's roast
beef right
now
like flavorless
you know
Shake Shack Chicken Shack is up next
this is the most expensive of any of the
burgers we've tried today
it looks pretty fancy
the bun is that classic Shake Shack bun
I think it's a potato roll
we have chicken
mayo and lettuce no pickles in this one
I was wrong
there are pickles in this one
the breading on the chicken it looked
like it was going to be tasty
but in actuality doesn't have that much
flavor and if you actually look at the
chicken it's quite a thick piece of
chicken
but it's like very dry and quite tough I
think it's probably worse than the MC
spicy so I'll tuck it in there
here we go let's get everyone fighting
in the comments we're Chick-fil-A never
been a Chick-fil-A fan and I hope
everyone watching can see what varieties
of chicken sandwiches you can get at any
fast food chain while you're picking
this what are you doing what are you
guys doing I've never really cared for
Chick-fil-A it's just the epitome of
fine I mean this is looking closer to to
these ones than it is to these over here
looks really dry
gotta get the sauce gotta put sauce on
it so I got
Chick-fil-A sauce
but I mean the fact that it's like no
you have to put sauce on it to enjoy it
well now can I put the sauce on it why
do I gotta do it
and I do really like the Chick-fil-A
sauce it's a very good sauce I will say
what this has going for it other than
these is that it's simplicity
makes it to me a little better because
it's not bogged down with like a lot of
like soggy vegetables or or sauce or
whatever when you add
in this instance the Chick-fil-A sauce
it is better so for that I'm going to
put it
let me put it down here
it's definitely not as good as a
McChicken
I just don't see what the big deal is I
don't and everyone's gonna flood my
comments with uh the specialty orders I
have to get with the sauces and then no
this is the sandwiches on the menu I got
it I tasted it boring and Bland up next
we've got Jollibee
the classic chicken sandwich also a
relatively new addition to the UK
okay
wow
I think it's the crispiest chicken we've
had so far I think it's even crispier
than the Popeyes one
could maybe benefit from a little bit
more Mayo it's just slightly driest my
main criticism so far there's not much
to separate this from Popeyes but I
think I slightly prefer the taste of
Popeyes
so I'll tuck it in now
yo Raising Canes though chicken tender
sandwiches someone's head chef is a 12
year old boy
um not a bad idea just stick the Tenders
in a bun throw some sauce on here let's
go
oh cool
hmm
here's why this is smart with the
tenders there's more surface there's
more like surface space
so the crispy skin to chicken ratio
leans more towards the crispy chicken or
the crispy skin which makes it just
gives it a lot more flavor wow
I really like raising cans and I was
disappointed
when put in this value Matrix that Harry
came up with but if you don't want
discount taste is a very tasty chicken
sandwich so oh
Raising Cane's another one that's famous
for having like this cane sauce you're
supposed to dip it in and I didn't even
put any on there it's still good so
Chick-fil-A yeah it's extra sauce then
we're on to the Wendy's classic chicken
sandwich well it looks like quite a dry
bun chicken party lettuce
ooh tomato and pickles
just visually I had quite low
expectations but
that's a pretty tasty sandwich not bad
I'm gonna put it slightly below it will
not crispy
all right last two
uh Shake Shack is great I don't usually
go there that often because I always
feel like it's a little bit more on the
expensive side and Aesthetics alone this
looks like it would have been
maybe the best one it looks like a big
piece of chicken
yeah
good amount of sauce I like the the bun
this looks like a big chicken sandwich
right
this is really good
yeah
the flavor of that chicken
is Popeyes and KFC level
I made it
canes is cool
everything this way has more of a
generic
fried chicken flavor but from here on
flavors are getting more specific which
I like and Shake Shacks wow then we've
got two UK exclusives to rank as well
I'm going to start with the Morley's
fillet Burger this kind of looks like
the platonic ideal chicken burger that
you might find
just the lettuce quite a lot of mayo
chicken was good not the thickest piece
of chicken but looks pretty well
seasoned
the chicken I would describe the texture
is leathery quality wise you can kind of
tell that the chicken in here is maybe
not quite as good as some of the other
ones I think it's down here actually not
as bad as the long chicken and last well
we've determined arguably the worst
value
for your money Carl's Jr
but they're really emphasizing that this
is a hand breaded they're doing it by
hand back there
hello
this section pretty good
oh man I've been dogging that Carl's Jr
all day
okay
all right Legend Kings is better than
this one but not I mean
it's close this one has a they both have
a unique flavor canes overall
has a better lasting flavor they don't
taste exactly the same but Carl's Jr
your hand breaded chicken sandwich is
actually pretty good then our final
option is the Nando's grilled chicken
burger it's some of their signature
grilled chicken with your chosen spice
level Leon chose the spiciest one for me
thank you and it served on these kind of
uh I think it's a Portuguese roll
which have quite a firm texture to them
and also you can taste the quality of
the chicken with this one the ratio is
slightly off I've always thought this
bun is like quite a lot
for the rest of the ingredients it's
good but where does it rank I think this
may upset people but I'm actually going
to put it slightly below them but crispy
and that is my ranking coming in dead
last Burger King chicken Royale and I
think my favorite is the Popeye's
Chicken Sandwich going down the raking
ranking from least to best says me in
last place we have was this Wendy's yeah
but of course
top two Popeyes and KFC and I want to
say
at any given day it could be Popeye's
one KFC too those guys are neck and neck
depending on the KFC and Popeyes you go
to oh my gosh I almost forgot Jollibee
this is the standard Jollibee sandwich
I'll put that between the McChicken and
the um
Chick-fil-A yeah not impressed it's a
lot of chicken to keep track of
now I'm going to talk about all the U.S
sandwiches you cannot get in the UK here
are all the chicken sandwiches from the
UK that you won't find in the US only we
call them chicken burgers firstly is the
return of the value King it's the Mayo
chicken
this is a simple cheap and cheerful As
It Gets it's a slightly oddly shaped
usually Square chicken patty with some
mayo and some lettuce on a bun and for a
few extra pans you can also add bacon
and have a bacon Mayo chicken then we
have a linguistic difference in the UK
our spicy version of the chicken
sandwich is called a MC spicy you guys
call yours a spicy MC crispy which to me
seems like an unnecessary amount of
words
whatever
I like spicy not crispy it's like a
pirate name
runs a KFC in the UK instead of having a
spicy chicken sandwich we have a Zinger
Burger
it's basically the same thing same Patty
but the breading is a bit more spicy
I quite like this I think generally
speaking I looked for a Zinger Burger
over just the Classic fillet burger also
do Americans find it weird that we
pronounce it fillet burger and not
fillet because I feel like you guys will
find that weird unless you're talking
about the phileo fish from McDonald's in
which case we say filet
figure it out our next exclusive from
KFC in the UK is the tower Burger
so this is the chicken but then they add
some cheese to it and a hash brown we've
also gone for the Zinger Tower burger
here which means that you got this spicy
salsari sauce
and then we have the exclusive Zinger
stacker Burger
now this is our largest burger that you
can find on a KFC UK menu
and it's if I can separate them which
apparently I can't it's just peeled
instead it's two chicken patties
with cheese between and on top
lettuce spicy mayo
and some more spicy sauce on top as well
while we're talking about the KFC ones
you'll note that on the UK menu they're
all named a burger rather than a
sandwich it's hard to explain exactly
where the linguistic difference comes
from I think a lot of it comes to do
with the bread that your sandwich comes
in I think generally speaking if you
have like a round bun particularly with
sesame seeds on it in the UK what's
inside it is just going to be called a
burger we actually have quite a few
chicken exclusives on a UK Burger King
menu we'll start with this one which is
the steakhouse crispy chicken
this is part of their Gourmet Kings menu
that's how I describe myself
there's a tomato resource on the bottom
a crispy chicken patty big slice of
cheese bacon and then what looks to be
some rocket on top
for the American audience we call
arugula rocket I've not had this one
before it was quite expensive I think
it's got Gourmet in the name and I think
they're using that to uh put this at
quite a high price point
it's not bad I do think
to get this as part of a meal you're
like pushing 10 pounds in the UK
and I feel like once you've hit that
price point just go somewhere else just
go to a restaurant because you'll get
like better quality fresher food
or probably the same if not even less
money there's a linguistic difference to
point out which is that in the UK we
call our weird long Burger King chicken
burger a chicken Royale in the UK we can
also get our chicken Royale with bacon
and cheese
or we can get a Californian barbecue
Royale
so that is the standard Royale with the
chicken
the lettuce and the mayor but also quite
a lot of barbecue sauce and also some
tomato on there surprisingly we actually
have a couple of Popeye's exclusive
sandwiches that you don't have in the US
here we have the deluxe chicken sandwich
and the spicy deluxe chicken sandwich
now while a regular Popeye sandwich is
just sauce
chicken and pickles these ones have
sauce chicken pickles but also lettuce
and cheese with the standard one the
sauce is Mayo
and on the spicy one
it's actually the sauce that changes
rather than the chicken
this one having a spicy mayo instead
I don't know if adding a little bit of
lettuce and cheese to something is
enough to qualify at this Deluxe
I think if you're calling something
Deluxe I'm going to need a little bit
more than that guys
but I'll give it a try
you know what
I'm gonna say it
I think the deluxe sandwiches are worse
than the originals from Popeyes I think
for that couple of extra pounds that is
costing you to add a little bit of
cheese and lettuce to your sandwich
you're better off without it honestly
the next exclusive is actually a bit
surprising to me it's this one from
Jollibee the double chicken sandwich
it's surprising in the sense that the UK
is the country of excess here for once
we're the ones with the
much larger portion this is a hefty
Hefty sandwich we have one exclusive
chicken sandwich from the UK Wendy's
which is the avocado chicken club so you
get the chicken patty with some cheese
on top
and then you have some mashed avocado
bacon lettuce and tomato not to be
outdone the UK also has quite a few
chicken chains that you won't find in
the U.S and interestingly our chicken
sandwich culture is quite different to
yours now in terms of chains Nando's is
obviously a pretty iconic chicken joint
over here in the UK now what you can
find some of these on the east coast of
the us over here they're in pretty much
every city in town and are kind of like
a foundational part of UK culture at
this point we're not so obsessed with
Peri Peri as a flavor that almost every
restaurant that sells chicken will have
a Peri-Peri option and you've seen lots
of other chains try and spring up to
capitalize on the popularity like
roosters and Pepes now we can't talk
about British chicken sandwiches without
talking about chicken shops chicken
shops are an integral part of UK and
more specifically London culture the big
players are morleys and chicken Cottage
but there are literally thousands of
independent ones scattered across the UK
they're so popular that people are
ripping off the big chains now so you'll
see things like monolies and moles
opening up with deceptively similar
branding and Decor to the classic
Morley's chain to put into context just
how popular Chicken Chops are there are
currently around 8 000 of them in London
McDonald's has just 200 locations a
funny thing is how some of the
independent chicken shops aren't just
ripping off other ones like Morley's but
they're trying to rip off the big chains
like KFC I think in the UK people don't
really understand what Fried Chicken
means when you refer it to a specific
U.S state so I'm sure to Americans they
will know the difference between
Kentucky Fried Chicken versus something
that was fried elsewhere but in the UK
we don't really have that context in the
UK you might walk down the street and
see Ohio Fried Chicken Maryland Fried
Chicken or Alaska Fried Chicken as an
American yes Kentucky does have a
distinct type of fried chicken
Popeyes Louisiana
other southern states have their own
ways of making fried chicken
yeah Nashville hot fried chicken that's
another one which is a city another
state yes I realize but yeah Alaska no
Ohio no Montana no no Montana has no
Cuisine another thing to point out is
that when it comes to the big chains
like Morley's and chicken Cottage the
individual shops are often franchised
Leon swears by the Thornton Heath
morleys he's a supplement guy and he
says the best one if you've been to a
better one let us know there isn't a bad
one
now I'm going to talk about all the U.S
sandwiches you cannot get in the UK
gonna go by Chain so McDonald's for
instance you can get a deluxe crispy
chicken sandwich which is the regular
chicken sandwich with
lettuce and tomato Mayo on it and then
you can also get the spicy version this
sauce is a little bit oranger which I
guess it makes it spicier Burger King I
saw it in there your what was it your
you guys call this
the the burger Royale and ours is just
the original crispy chicken sandwich
sub sandwich it's shaped like that for
seemingly no specific reason yep KFC
the Chicken Little that's a little guy
you can also get your Chick-fil-A
Sandwich spicy version
um that looks spicier it comes in a red
bag because red is hot and spicy is hot
I mean everything that Carl's Jr was a
exclusive I think because you guys don't
even have one
it just seems like
we're kind of throwing everything at the
wall and see what sticks crispy chicken
with bacon
I feel that Wendy's especially Wendy's
and Carl's Jr they just are trying to
like
do variations on a theme hoping that
we'll kind of get everyone I understand
why but it's a bit overwhelmed right I
mean I don't even know which one to get
I don't wanna I don't wanna bite any of
these they don't look bad
this whole section here is just like
throw everything in the wall and see
what sticks you know
I don't agree with that strategy guys
just by the looks of all these
sandwiches
the flagship chicken sandwich at each
one of the chains I would more go for
than any of these I'm just
I don't want any of these
I say fellow fish
yeah it's the only time yeah thank you
yeah Leon's backing me up on this
what about filet mignon
yeah but that's like a whole French
thing because you're not saying Philip
mignon
you're pronouncing
I love the Philip mignon please